what is happening reject nation that I
focus the camera parently it was so if
I'm Greg out but I'm John Humphrey
welcome to the real rejects and today
we're going to do something special you
know why because its patron of the
daytime patron or Nadine Wilkes anything
will tear down on deaf or said anything
aren't your thank you letter to you it's
gonna take forever to get there any cost
Orillia years to get to you it'll be
covered in stamps and they'll probably
be opened and like there will be [ __ ]
inside of it like but because of his
pledge request his cheer allows him to
whatever video he requested we talk
about something or react to something we
got to do it and he's an Aussie this
awesome mofo it has us to check out a
video called here comes the boom afl's
biggest hits all about the rugby and no
he said don't call it rugby it's Aussie
Rules Football I'm Connor rugby oh I'm
sorry I ruined the joke there that's
what I'm here for have tits you off
that's what I do to patrons
I just anger them why did I pledge boy
at all I played you were your the
community boyfriend boy I know it it no
quote on the same I've never seen Aussie
Rules Football yeah I would love to know
what that is like I just feel like
everything is harder Corey I'm a little
big
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
Galleria to the music right whoa my
grandma would love I didn't like Bobby
my ni cap right this is what along out
and velocity oh yeah let's remind me of
that oh damn you Josh and reliable Wow
it's right into it this sucka this is
like the real versions of Scott sterling
sketching see that yeah I don't still
ticks and again all of these people like
even the worst player on this team is
tougher them know about it step on their
face oh oh
[Music]
this is what reaction videos for me oh
thank [ __ ] it out hug it out oh oh that
could have been worse I could have been
a lot worse
it always won't with wait
I ain't going to tickle him back down
ouch I don't understand why don't we're
here you know these are crazy cuz
they're hard cooler because everything
wants to kill you Wow Wow
I never want to play this game I
wouldn't even play this game to vlog in
and get you look sound of incredibly
famous yeah I feel like I would just
joke like I said I would need to train
so heavily before doin
Wow she gotta just be radiant hurdle
it'll be a tough dude my guys ready
physically tough going I added it yeah
you know I would love to see it in life
I would yeah would never blame it is a
reasonable average how many people died
playing concussion showed a bit about it
I know what innovation it is exactly
here is a new [ __ ]
Matt's play this game how are get up
right we can't even elbow with that side
in MMA this whole time I've been
watching people smash each other but but
what is that ball like that's such a
weird look involved I've never seen a
ball like that my gosh it is kind of
halfway between football rugby and just
being a bat it probably they wear
helmets and stuff at least like they
have like little hands yeah yeah Ellen
airs called Australia football league
Aussie Rules AFL yeah that matters
Saudis football league I got it the
words football it has gotten so
confusing
because the room looks like some of the
ones for where every nation just goes no
this is what I had and we all just don't
agree I think if I were to watch this on
TV now I would be spoiled because the
whole time I want to be enjoying the
game I just be like when someone get
hurt this is going to be it like this is
the kind of game that makes you
bloodthirsty because you like especially
who is your first introductions a couple
yeah I'd be like I don't care about the
points just leveled it hurting that's
like what I would play those hockey
games on like Nintendo or just wake you
to the boxing part and then whenever I
watch a hockey match like where is our
party each other yeah
I really care to learn the physics of
India hug do something punch someone you
want to play us all or not about I feel
like I feel like all those watching it
live if I went to Australia I'd be like
a guy go to one of these games whatever
it costs oh yeah sure Elia I will pay
even more money now where to attend one
of these I would love to go there I mean
like I'm gonna laminate my body before I
go to Australia yeah because you know
there's crazy stuff around every turn I
would yeah I would definitely make going
to see one of these the priority because
I bet the crowds are fun to like being
in that way out it seems like sports
like these rile up the rest of the world
more than American a little bit I love
our football and you know basketball
base one of these guys that our stuff
also the team rivalries in the crowd
like I bet that's got to be you know I'm
not gonna get mixed up and I bet the
crowd hurts each other yeah you know
I've been doing all other compilation
videos people to stand and exact extreme
not show passing or whatever you know
whatever your snack is Nathan Wilson
there you go buddy thanks for sending
that to us ma'am I enjoyed watching that
that's part of what makes reactions fun
this videos like this yeah not Marvel
movies not DC movies not game at the
Rome's
not action films not franchises watching
people beat the [ __ ] out of each other
during Australian football that was
awesome nothing nothing will ever
replace the gladiator guys you can
subscribe to the real rejects
Mickleham deck on Nathan Sultan or
Wilton just now I don't know maybe you
maybe will get Nathan in Cillian because
that's always that's always a safety net
that John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram
I'm Greg Alva I live to please my